Mark Steyn is an author a columnist and
by the way an immigrant will let him
decide whether his homeland was any sort
of hole he joins us tonight so mark I
mean maybe I'm you know miss reading
this and maybe there are things the
president said that I didn't hear I'm
sure there were but from what I could
hear he was saying look why would we
give apparently preference to poor
countries over rich ones and that
doesn't seem like a crazy thing to say
well I think he's actually saying why
should we give preference to
dysfunctional societies over over others
and and I'll say it if hos they won't
until 50 years ago every nation on earth
every Western nation particularly
thought it had the right to discriminate
when it came to immigration among those
countries and those people who would
find it easier to assimilate and
contribute to the country they were
moving to and if Jose thinks you don't
like black people or brown people let's
keep it all black I think it's I don't
think I I agree with the president I
wish he'd formulated it more elegantly
but Haiti is a bleep hole or whatever
you want to call it
Barbados isn't st. Kitts isn't Grenada
isn't Santa Lucia isn't there are
distinctions one can make even within
quite small groups of countries and as
to Joan Walsh refusing to say whether
she'd rather move to Haiti or Norway
let's not wait for Joan let's wait for
the let's just look at the existing
traffic there are immigrants all over
the world who moved to Norway
nobody voluntarily moves to Haiti why is
that because it's a dysfunctional
society and so are many of the others
from which America's present ludicrous
immigration system takes new comers for
us so here's my my question so China is
the most aggressive colonial power in
the world right now and it's investing
all over Africa and all over Latin
America all over the Caribbean playing
thirty billion dollars in Haiti for
example there's no pressure from John
wall's for the American left for the
Chinese to absorb
immigration from any of those regions at
all they're not denounced as racist for
keeping their borders totally closed to
everybody why is that I wonder
well because China is allowed to advance
its own interest so it's bought for
example a big ton of bulk sites in
Jamaica the bauxite industry in Jamaica
but it doesn't feel that along with that
it has to import a big bunch of
Jamaicans to its country and that is
that is when when people like people get
object to what President Trump says but
it magically makes far more sense than
if you look at what pat leahy said you
just say oh just sent out this a unit
tweet in response bleating that's not
who we are it's not enough actually just
to say that's not who we are
and in fact that's the response to every
one of these so-called problem that's
not who we are they never actually say
who we are
they just say that's not who we are and
who we are seems to be devolving down
into the people who say that's not who
we are everybody else
China Haiti Norway is allowed to be who
we are and act as a nation in its own
national interests including on
immigration policy yeah well I think
China can use all more diversity so well
we will be pushing for that in future
weeks thanks a lot more appreciate
exactly thanks Erica